I have not felt safe in my country for a long time.
I strongly suspect that also applies to you.
"I fell in love with this country I fell in love with the German
language I fell in love with the German guiding culture.
"
And yet I miss the fatherland that I met many years ago.
I came here because of the German guiding culture.
But what happened to it?
I am often asked why I joined the AfD.
You,
as a native Brazilian,
you with your accent,
you are a foreigner.
Well,
the reasons why I joined the AfD are very diverse but the main reasons everyone
can understand when thinking about something Security Inflation Corona domestic
policy fundamental rights as well as the current Green Energy Policy.
There is only one party for Germany it is the AfD.